welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast
in today's episode we have some big
updates from the stronger by science
universe
we've got a research review segment in
which we discuss multiple beta alanine
related supplements
greg's got a research roundup segment
where he talks about the relationship
between strength and hypertrophy
potential
sticking points training frequency
non-nutritive sweeteners and more
we've got a coach's corner segment where
we talk about how to modify your
pressing exercises
in the presence of elbow and shoulder
pain and we wrap things up by answering
a few questions from listeners
as always thank you for listening and we
hope you enjoy the show
welcome back to the stronger buy science
podcast this is your host eric trexler
and today i'm joined by a very special
very temporary guest
co-host his name is greg knuckles and
greg is the founder of stronger by
science he completed the
master of arts program in exercise
science at unc chapel hill
he's held three all-time world records
in power lifting
in the 220 and 242 pound weight classes
and he's coached hundreds of athletes
both in person
and online greg thanks for joining us
i really hated that i hope that does not
become a standard part of the intro
uh but yeah it's it's a pleasure thank
you thank you for having me on
uh how's life treating you trex things
are good with me what about you
doing pretty well awesome so we got a
lot to cover
in the show today uh so let's jump right
into some good news
and i would be happy to start us off
here so
my good news involves science which is a
good thing
generally team science over here so
i was looking at the news and i saw that
some researchers
implanted a microchip
into somebody's brain this gentleman
was paralyzed due to a spinal cord
injury in 2007.
he had lost all movement below the neck
but by using this
uh implanted microchip technology he was
able
actually able to uh to write sentences
uh using just his brain uh pretty
incredible stuff so
uh this microchip uh they kind of
developed this interface where he could
kind of do like a
thought to text kind of program
um and so yeah he was able to just kind
of think the words that he wanted to
to say and then uh it worked so it was
pretty incredible and like
i'm not gonna like pretend to be a
neuroscientist uh
just for the sake of the good news
segment but it was really impressive and
i'll put the link
in the show notes if you want to get
more information about how the microchip
system works
but basically there's these two
microchips they're about the size of a
baby aspirin
they were implanted one millimeter into
the gentleman's brain
in 2017 and uh yeah
it's pretty incredible stuff so um the
guy basically
was instructed to imagine that he was
using his hand
to write on a notepad and then the
computer converted those thoughts into
text
on a computer screen and the speed and
the error rate
that they recorded in this experiment
were really
quite impressive so really exciting
stuff it's always great when
when you see these kinds of stories of
of scientists doing this really
impactful work
uh in you know creating new technologies
and new systems that can
really impact people's lives like that
so uh
score one for team science hopefully
this will be something that can be
scalable
and kind of get out there and really
help a lot of people i i wonder if this
was like
independently funded research or if this
was
uh kind of like the first consumer
usage of uh old darpa research
i have no idea yeah so uh do you know
about darpa
i've heard of it okay so i forget what
the acronym stands for but it's
um it's basically a funding body
backed by the us armed services that
funded
uh like provided funding and just like
basic science
research grants for things that they
were hoping would eventually have
military applications
and i think it like so probably the most
well-known darpa funded thing
is probably the internet um but
i remember when i first learned about
darpa in college
uh there was just like uh i think
i think there was a wikipedia page that
just went through
stuff that people knew about that darpa
was funding
at the time and it was probably funding
other stuff as well that people didn't
know about
but one of the things that they were
funding was
what sounds like this so this sounds
kind kind of like the first step
of what they were working towards
basically they wanted a way for
soldiers in the field to do what would
basically amount to
sight like psychic communication so
if like people were going in somewhere
where
you know theoretically there are enemies
that could hear them they're trying to
make as little sound as possible
like people on a team being able to
communicate with each other without
having to be able to talk
so like purely just brain to brain
communication
and this sounds like the first step of
that like you can convert
thoughts to words and then you know on
the on the back end you would need a way
to convert
those words to something that's
interpretable
so yeah at this point you could probably
just do it via like an earpiece
but i think they were thinking
communicate directly
from one brain to another without any
sound waves whatsoever
um so anyway that's that's what this
made me think of
well that would certainly be cool as
well but yeah good stuff
yeah so uh for for my good news
uh i've talked about this before
generally looking for good news stories
just makes me depressed because
um oftentimes they take the very
depressing form of here's this major
problem in the world
that could be easily solved and here's
someone
doing individual actions that uh you
know
should be kind of like a problem that
could be solved collectively
uh in any way i don't like it it bums me
out
uh so i'm just going to talk about some
some positive things going on in my life
just trying to get the good vibes
rolling so
uh first back at trivia i'm
super stoked about this uh it's it's the
one
uh it's the one thing i do with other
people outside of work
throughout the week until the weekends
i'm very very extroverted so it's
it's like a huge felt need but i
obviously didn't do it
throughout the pandemic so feels good to
be back at trivia
if you happen to live in or near raleigh
north carolina and you want to do some
really really fun trivia
you should come to hammer trivia with
thor at ruckus pizza
in mission valley it is 8 p.m on
wednesdays and it is the best trivia
i've ever done
very fun second positive thing nba
playoffs are here
best time of the year uh it's like a
month and a half long celebration of all
of the best things about sports
uh because the best sport is of course
basketball
uh and honestly this has been
the best first round of the nba playoffs
that i can remember
uh generally first rounds are mostly
snoozers you might get a competitive
four or five
match up or a competitive three six
match up uh but ultimately
you generally don't care about those too
much because they're probably just gonna
get
smacked in the later rounds anyways
uh but overall like they've been pretty
competitive
matchups up and down the board
throughout the playoffs so far
uh and it's it's been great um
so i i'm very excited to see how that
goes
uh third positive thing so i talked
about on the last
podcast i'd recently uh broken my
arm or i think i said i thought i'd
broken my arm but it hadn't been
confirmed yet i don't remember
anyway i did break my wrist uh and
jacked up some stuff in my elbow as well
uh
it's still not a hundred percent
obviously broken bones take a while to
heal
but function is returning a lot faster
than i anticipated
so uh i've got mostly full range of
motion back
grip is still really weak but i can do
activities of daily living again
without too much discomfort so that is
very positive
um on that topic do you mind telling
people what happened just so
i've been getting a lot of nasty
messages accusing me of being
responsible
uh yeah so uh yeah
we eric and i had a dispute
about uh i i mean i don't want to get
into it too much but something related
to the business finances
uh i stormed out of the room i think i
was justified in doing so
and he pushed me head first down the
stairs so
hopefully that clears everything up but
we we have buried the hatchet
yes uh and we won't be making those
mistakes again which is perfect for both
of us
correct it is funny though because i did
get some joking messages
uh accusing me of harming you and
breaking your arm but
it reminded me when i was in high school
um
me and my best friend uh we played in a
3-3-5 d front defense in football
so he was the free safety over the top
in the middle and i was the strong
safety
uh so we played next to each other on
the field and we played this really big
game that was televised
and he actually broke his arm during the
game and
we were hanging out at his place that
night and we're like let's watch the
game it's it's on tv
like a rerun of it and while i was at
his house just hanging out after the
game we found out that actually i broke
his arm
oh no because we played next to each
other the running back was coming
up the middle and we converged to make
the tackle we thought it was the running
back's fault but like
my helmet just destroyed his arm and uh
so that was a very uncomfortable
conversation but uh
i did break his arm i did not break
yours uh
well i mean we we now have uh
officially on the record that you did
fair enough um
but no it was playing basketball uh
going up for a rebound
someone hit me from behind fell on my
outstretched left arm uh
i can still jump pretty well and i weigh
quite a bit
so there was a lot of force going
through my left arm uh so that's what
happened
a a standard foosh injury if you will
uh speaking of which wayne quite a bit
good segway i'm i'm now nesting a new
segment
within the good news segment because
ideally there will only be good news
every time this segment comes up and
that is my
road to the stage segment um
i have decided so i i've been
just kind of like vacillating between
hey i want to cut some weight and hey i
want to get strong for like the last
five years or so uh and i've decided
[ __ ] it i'm gonna put this out here
publicly just as kind of a
an accountability mechanism i i'm really
uh dedicating myself to this cut
um i'm about uh well so
i i set myself three goals well four
goals really to start with
i made it to my first goal which was to
get below 250 again
that was new as of this morning
congratulations to me
i'm halfway to my second goal which is
to get below 235
that is a number of import to me because
that is what i weighed
at my wedding and i have not been below
that
since my wedding uh we ate a lot on our
honeymoon
it was great uh but yeah anyway so
halfway to that and then i'm a third of
the way
to my first big goal which is to get
below 220 again
so that's what i weighed for the last
meet i did at 220.
ate a lot after that meet have not been
below 220
since um and then i'm about a
quarter of the way to where i think i'm
probably gonna wrap this up which is to
get down to around
205 give or take um
actually you know i'll i'll probably
push it to a shade below 200. yeah i was
going to say get below 200.
yeah just to see what that looks like i
i i'm kind of hung up on doing things in
like 15 pound
increments because everything else has
worked out to 15 pound increments so
well
yeah uh but yeah no i i'm interested to
see what that'll look like
because the last time i was below 200 i
got down to 190
after my first semester of college and
that was
at a time where i was pretty much just
like crash dieting
and not lifting at all and like i was
fairly lean and looked pretty good
at 190 then so i mean i'm
planning on continuing to lift all the
way down so
i mean hopefully hopefully i look sick
uh and if i don't that's fine i probably
won't
honestly i probably have a very weird
physique uh because i've pretty much
only done squat binge deadlift for the
last
decade plus um but you know what that's
fine
uh and there and there's only one way to
find out absolutely
and so i guess this is where you reveal
basically that our whole
um diet app that we're building is just
a selfish project to keep you on track
basically
i mean kind of but not really
it has actually been really huge though
because i think my
i think one of my biggest psychological
hang-ups with cutting before
is i so my my weight fluctuates a lot
like it can fluctuate up to
like eight to ten pounds or more over
the span of two or three days
and i think i would just let that get in
my head quite a bit
um and you know if
if it was trending up for like three or
four days straight i'd be like oh no my
deficit isn't big enough and then if i
make a much larger deficit i think uh
well i mean i'm probably just losing a
bunch of muscle i think i'm going way
too fast
uh and also i just really hated logging
my nutrition
mostly because the apps that were out
there were
very clunky and annoying for that like i
i did not want to
have to wrestle with myfitnesspal for
like five minutes every time i logged a
meal to
swipe through 30 different options to
figure out the one where i thought the
nutrition information was actually
correct
so the app has been pretty huge because
i can log stuff way quicker
and i know the math behind it so
i i know that when the app is telling me
to eat
uh like 2 700 calories per day i know
that's correct
because like i know the formulas that go
into it and
it it must be correct uh if what we know
about physics is true
uh and thus far that that has been
working out
um yeah and it's it's been great that's
what i love about it is like
you know that the number on there is
exactly what you would have gotten if
you sat down and spent like 30 minutes
doing a bunch of calculations and
estimates and stuff yeah because like
you know we've been just
killing ourselves over the details
making sure all the calculations are
are what we want so no it's been really
exciting to have that
that access to just really easy tracking
and like
you and i i think are both um i think
the technical term is stubborn bastards
is that accurate sure yeah so like yeah
i
there are many ways to get an estimate
but i prefer our estimate
over anybody else's but uh but yeah so
um we aren't gonna hoard that forever it
will be coming out
at some point in the future and we're
excited to share that but
not until it's 100 ready
uh so that brings me to some other
stronger by science news
uh first of all i forgot to mention the
uh the bulk supplements.com discount
last episode and probably several other
episodes
but rest assured if you have any
supplement needs
you go down to bulksupplements.com you
type in the code
sbs pod in all caps and that gets you
a five percent discount on your your
supplement order
yeah after our last episode we got a
very strongly worded
uh email from one of their enforcers fat
tony
uh and he said if we didn't mention it
on this podcast
that in addition to my broken wrist they
would break our kneecaps
uh so please please use that code we uh
we desperately need that correct and we
desperately need
all of our kneecaps as well correct yeah
so
um on top of that even more good news
for stronger by science we recently
hired two new coaches
which is really awesome so we hired
jacob green who is a registered
dietitian
he's also working on his master's right
now in grant tinsley's lab
and if you're listening and you've been
a long time listener you know that we've
had
grant tinsley on the show before you
know that we talk about his research
every few weeks it seems because he does
a lot of really cool body composition
and uh you know nutrition metabolism
stuff so he does a lot of
time restricted feeding resting
metabolic rate
predictive equations body comp analysis
a lot of cool stuff out at tinsley's lab
and we actually do like believe in the
stuff we talk about
so like you know when we're looking for
people to hire like
if we know that you're working and
studying under grant we're like okay
i like that you know you know enough
about this stuff to a found grant
that's a good sign um but yeah so jacob
green he's a registered dietitian
uh we're really stoked to have him on
board and then we've also got pack and
you know pack better than i do do you
want to give a little uh shout out to
pack there
uh yeah so he's uh he's a phd student
um working under james steele
out in the uk uh so pack
his his real name is patroclus
much like achilles's sidekick in the
iliad which
is very cool uh big homer fans on the
podcast
uh but yeah he he's great um he
does really cool research he he recently
finished up
data collection for his phd looking at
the minimum effective dose of
uh resistance training for strength
development
in people with prior training experience
so
very cool very practical stuff uh also
just a very funny guy
very good online footprint i would say
both on twitter and instagram so
if you're interested in a coach he's
excellent uh you know both
uh both very scientifically astute and
also a big meat head
which i think is the perfect combination
that you're looking for
and just a great guy all around yeah
we're really excited about hiring both
these coaches really talented folks
and uh you know we don't make coaching
hires
that often so right now we do have some
open
spots on our rosters with within the
stronger by science coaching team
so if you've been thinking about
applying for coaching with one of our
coaches
now would be the time to apply because
those rosters are probably going to fill
up pretty quickly
and then you know you might get wait
listed if you
apply after that point so now would be a
great time to
apply for coaching we do one-time
consultations month-to-month coaching
we do annual coaching programs
and uh yeah you can do training only
nutrition only or a combination of both
uh okay so how about some feats of
strength from greg
yeah yeah let's do it so i've got two
this time around well two and a half
you'll see um
so one of them was joy nomani
um she is a 40
57 kilo usa pl ipf
uh competitive lifter uh 57 kilos that's
the 125 pound weight class
uh she currently holds the world record
deadlift in that weight class
at 213 and a half kilos or 471 pounds
she recently posted a gym lift of her
pulling 227 and a half kilos or 501
pounds in training
um and uh you know a lot of training
lifts especially on the deadlift
people might use a deadlift bar if they
compete with a stiff bar
or they might use straps she pulled this
on what appeared to be a power bar and
without straps
so you know under the same sort of
conditions that one would
in competition so she she looks to be
good for it on the platform
um that would extend her own record to
nearly 50 pounds ahead of the number two
uh lifter in that weight class and it's
also only 12 and a half kilos off of
steffy cohen's untested record in that
weight class which uh
i mean we're we're big fans of steffy on
the pod obviously an excellent
deadlifter
um so for for joy to be in
for joy to be a tested lifter closing in
on
those levels of deadlift strength and
honestly
just to pull over 500 pounds at 125. uh
absolutely wild uh hope she hits it in
her next meet
very very very strong and number two
uh and also number two and a half uh
gerald uh dionio uh
totaled 740 kilos or 1631 pounds
in the 148 pound weight class or the 67
and a half kilo class
uh that is a new uh raw with wraps
untested world record in that weight
class uh that beats out
michael estrella by two kilograms
very very strong that's um
i want to say that's around where the
record at 181 was when i started
competing
so the fact that people are doing that
at 148 now
uh absolutely wild uh but when i was
when i was looking those numbers up on
open powerlifting
one of the things that jumped out to me
on the page was that tony conyers
still has the number four total all time
in that class
uh he was the former all-time world
record holder
at 148 and he hit his total of
uh 1585 or 719 kilos
at the ripe young age of 58 years old
so i was just curious when i saw that
like how much stronger is tony conyers
or was tony conyers and other people of
approximately his age when he hit that
total
uh and it's absolutely insane so he
totaled 15.85 the next closest total
in that weight class uh was 11.85
so he was like 400 pounds and
uh like 33
ahead of second place in that weight
class uh
and also just in terms of individual
lifts for people in his weight class at
his age
uh squats 150 pounds more than anyone
else
benches 40 pounds more than anyone else
and deadlifts
almost 100 pounds more than anyone else
so
um just a a true
freak performance um from
someone at 58 years old probably
if you account for both weight class and
also
age that might be
the biggest outlier performance in
powerlifting history
if not it's relatively close to it
awesome that's really really impressive
uh strong people doing strong things i
it always blows me away when you look at
like
the records from you know when i was
really following powerlifting closely it
was like
2012. and you look at the records now
and compare them to back then and it's
just like you just have to like shift
everything to weight classes
you know like yeah what what used to be
good in one weight class
uh now is good two weight classes below
that which is just
it's really mind-blowing um all right so
let's move forward and talk about some
science here uh
i know i've got a research roundup and i
know you've got
some research to cover as well so let's
dive right into it
my research roundup is about beta
alanine
and related compounds so
it's really interesting um the beta
alanine literature
is there have been a few papers
lately that have been pretty eye-opening
when it comes to beta alanine and that i
feel like that's kind of
unexpected for a lot of people because
you think of beta alanine as something
that's been around for a while or at
least been
in the general consciousness of lifters
for a while so you would think that we
have
all the basic stuff totally hammered out
by now
but that's really not necessarily the
case we still have
the literature is still young enough for
beta alanine that we can still have
these papers come out that kind of
really reframe the way we look at it the
way we think about it could have some
practical
significance now i do want to put a
little caveat at the beginning here
some of this information is a bit
speculative um
i mean that that is inherently the risk
you run when you talk about
newer research that's kind of on the
cutting edge is that
you know it hasn't been tested in like
35 different randomized controlled
trials so
there's a little bit of speculation here
but some interesting new uh
findings i want to briefly discuss about
beta alanine
so the reason we take beta-alanine
is because you can combine beta-alanine
and histidine and create carnosine and
you can store that in your muscles
and so in humans we store carnosine in
our muscles
it does a lot of different things but
when we think about it for performance
reasons the most important stuff is it
can facilitate ph buffering
it can help us buffer some of those
protons that accumulate during high
intensity glycolytic exercise
that can help sustain high intensity
performance
especially if we're talking about any
kind of sprint work
or like glycolytic short rest period
work that's happening
over the span of a couple minutes to
maybe 10 minutes or so
and so in humans we've got carnosine
that we store in muscle to take care of
that
but there are other histidine containing
dipeptides so carnosine
fits in there but there's also anserine
and there's uh something called ophidine
and these are basically like methylated
analogues of carnosine
and different mammals have different
combinations
of these uh histidine-containing
dipeptides
uh and and it's really cool when you
look uh at some of the comparative
physiology and you look at how different
animals have these different amounts of
histidine
containing dipeptides in their muscles
like
you look at i think there's some pretty
incredibly
high levels in like mammals that live in
the ocean
that have to do really extended dives
under water
because i mean they're mammals right i
mean it's not like they can just
bring in some oxygen through their gills
or anything
but you know they have to be able to
stay underwater for a while and do a lot
of anaerobic metabolism without coming
up for another breath
and so they're they they have some i
mean they have
a million interesting aspects to their
physiology but one of the things is they
tend to have
really high levels of these
histidine-containing compounds to
facilitate
all of the buffering necessary for that
prolonged period of anaerobic metabolism
so i think i think horses as well have
some pretty impressive levels in their
muscles which is
one of the reasons that they can go and
go and go at high intensities
so in humans uh we only store
carnosine in our muscles but you know
these
other histidine-containing dipeptides
are becoming fairly interesting uh
when we look at the research people have
started investigating
um the feasibility of supplementing
uh with so you know typically we think
of supplementing with beta alanine which
is great it combines with histidine
we store it in our muscles for more of a
long-term chronic supplementation
uh strategy but in the short term people
are looking at what would happen if we
supplement with
a combination of carnosine and anserine
which is one of those
methylated analogues of carnosine and so
the reason that you might do that there
are some logistical challenges
when it comes to carnosine
supplementation because some people are
like hey
let's just supplement with carnosine and
that way acutely we'll have plenty of
carnosine in the blood
it'll be doing what we're trying to do
with beta-alanine supplementation anyway
well there's an issue there and that is
the fact that
carnosine itself is broken down by a
very
active enzyme in the blood called human
serum carnosinase one and so what
happens is you know you might wanna do
acute supplementation with uh with
carnosine itself
but it's gonna be very rapidly broken
down in the bloodstream
into beta alanine and histidine
and so then the beta alanine is going to
go to the muscle and and all that other
stuff so
the the idea of doing acute
supplementation with carnosine alone
uh doesn't seem to work out and does
come with the challenges that we
associate with high-dose beta-alanine
so if you take a bunch of it more likely
to have a headache
more likely to have all that tingling
that we call paresthesia
but what's really interesting is that
people have been looking into
a different approach and what they're
doing
is uh giving a combination of
carnosine and and serine
and so this kind of gets around some of
the issues
associated with just doing high-dose
carnosine supplementation
so basically what happens is the
ansarine itself
is way less susceptible to that
breakdown from that enzyme in the blood
and so the idea is you give a high dose
of carnosine which
saturates that carnosinase enzyme
you combine it with a pretty high dose
of anserine which is
more resistant to that enzyme and you
might be able to actually induce some
acute effects that might not be possible
with just doing carnosine alone
or just doing beta alanine alone and
what's really fascinating is that for
some reason
the side effects you would associate
with high dose carnosine
they don't seem to be quite as bad if
you give kind of an equal mixture of
carnosine and anserine
which is really really fascinating and
like i said we're
we're teetering on to the cutting edge
here so it's very possible a wave of
like six new studies will come in
and say no that was just a fluke the
side effects are equivalent but
for now they have shown that like
instead of giving
a 60 milligram per kilogram dose of
carnosine
you can give 30 and 30 carnosine and
anserine
and it has a much better profile in
terms of the paresthesia and the
headache susceptibility
so anyway there there have been a couple
studies that have come out that have
kind of caught my attention
where they've applied this strategy and
they've been able to induce
obviously acute increases in serum
levels of carnosine
and anserine but also like i said a
really nice
profile in terms of side effects and
adverse effects
just the general discomfort we see with
high-dose carnosine supplementation
and and there have been some preliminary
studies showing some
some fairly positive effects when it
comes to uh
you know short-term glycolytic exercise
performance so
this stuff is very much in its infancy
but if you're
if you're interested in beta alanine and
you kind of like nerding out on the
physiology behind it i think it's a
really fascinating thing to look at
here we'll see if it turns out to be a
really promising strategy in terms of
you know
improving various types of performance
but you know
the the mechanisms involved here when we
talk about you know carnosine's effects
in muscle
of course we're talking about buffering
ph and also potentially
increasing calcium sensitivity of
myofibrils potentially
facilitating muscle force output but the
idea is
you could basically do long-term
supplementation more chronic
supplementation with beta-alanine
build up your muscular storage of
carnosine but then before exercise bouts
supplement with this combination of
carnosine and anserine
and that would increase blood levels of
these histidine-containing dipeptides
which could further facilitate some of
that buffering that's going on during
high-intensity exercise
so that's a new strategy and like i said
it caught my eye because it's a little
bit
novel um you know you look at
things they've even i've seen some
studies that
look at supplementing with chicken meat
extracts uh
and so you'd look at that if it was in
the title of a study and
be like okay that's weird going to
scroll right past it but
when you look at chicken meat extracts
they typically do
have high concentrations of these
compounds
and they usually have a ratio of
carnosine to anserine
of like one to two or one to three
so this particular research group i'm
going to put some links in the show
notes if you want to dig a little bit
deeper
into this body of research but this
particular group has a
a really keen interest in these chicken
meat extracts because they do provide
uh the multiple histidine-containing
dipeptides
within a kind of naturally occurring
food matrix which is pretty fascinating
um but yeah i've got a question that i'm
sure other people will ask
sure uh so it's the classic like
creatine and beef question like oh can i
just eat enough beef that i don't have
to supplement with creatine
uh since this stuff is in chicken meat
do you know if like cooking chicken meat
breaks it down
or if if one were to consume basically
all of their protein from chicken
would their bases be covered um i'd have
it's been a long time since i looked
into the actual
like raw value concentrations within
meats
i definitely can't answer that on the
fly but
just just to give an idea of the dosing
we're talking about it looks like
this research group is really fond of
the dosing protocol
using uh 30 milligrams per kilogram of
each
and so like if you weigh 80 kilograms
that would be
uh 2.4 grams of each so it'd be 4.8
grams of the
of the total if you go 30 and 30. so
what's really fascinating to me with
this uh this particular line of inquiry
is that uh you know like i said giving
60 milligrams per kilogram
of pure carnosine if you're 80 kilograms
that'd be like 4.8 grams and that that
induces headache and paresthesia in like
40 of subjects that that's not fun
uh but if you go 30 and 30 with these
two different compounds combined
we're talking about 2.4 grams of each
and and that seems to be doing a pretty
good job of
alleviating or circumventing those
adverse symptoms so
i i would struggle to believe that you
could get that from chicken meat itself
i wonder if maybe there's a type of
broth out there that might be able to do
it but i'm really not certain i'd have
to double check on that but
but it's a fascinating look at a fairly
novel perspective with regards to these
beta alanine related
compounds and potential supplementation
strategies and again
it's important to really delineate the
distinction here
so when we talk about beta alanine
we're trying to build up long-term
muscle storage of carnosine
and the advantage of these combined
supplementation with these alternative
histidine containing compounds is
they're trying to target
acute supplementation given you know
directly before an exercise bout because
beta alanine itself we do not expect it
to have much of an acute effect
whatsoever i see you're googling
furiously over there anything to report
yeah i i think it might be possible
actually
um but again i don't know how heat
affects this
yeah so the molar mass of carnosine
is 226.3 grams per mole
i see another one of these figures in
your paper
or in your outline looking at muscle
carnosine
concentrations in humans um so
without beta alanine supplementation
about 20
millimoles per kilogram uh
so if we assume that that
is similar for chickens uh
so 20 millimoles divided by a thousand
to get
millimoles you you'd wind up with like
uh 4.5
grams of carnosine per kilogram
i don't know that would be for human
flesh
uh i don't know what those levels would
look like for chickens and again
i don't eat don't eat human flesh i mean
but if you did
want four and a half grams of carnosine
from human flesh
a kilogram raw might get you there uh
again
not recommending it wink wink um but
anyway
if those levels happen to be similar in
chickens and if heat doesn't affect it
a kilogram of chicken meat would would
get you close but i
i suspect it probably breaks down due to
heat i think most things do
i i think heat would be an issue and i
would also be
cautious about um the actual meat
content of chicken just because
the species to species variation is very
substantial
um and different species have different
relative amounts of these different
histidine-containing dipeptides so
uh we can look into it and see if we can
find a way there with food for sure but
we're not so to be clear we're not
recommending
you eat a kilogram of chicken sashimi
per day
but we're not recommending you don't do
that either
i'm recommending that you don't okay i
don't want to speak for you
um so so that's the one side is this new
research that's coming out
very preliminary but very interesting
looking at
other histidine-containing compounds um
but beta-alanine itself i i don't
remember exactly how much of this i've
discussed on the podcast but it's a good
time to revisit it because
there's more information about beta
alanine dosing and washout that's become
available
so like i said beta-alanine we're trying
to increase
muscle storage of carnosine so we can
use it later when we need it
i was at a conference several years ago
and i bumped into roger harris and
i think you and i were buddies at the
time we didn't like work together or
anything like that
but i i think this was around that time
frame where i was like dude you're never
going to believe this
but so roger harris is staring at this
poster which is pretty atypical you
don't see a lot of like
really like senior level researchers
presenting posters at a lot of
conferences maybe at like the really
fancy prestigious ones
but um usually a lot of students present
preliminary findings
with posters so like roger harris if
you're not familiar with him
he's like the the big dog in creatine
research and the big dog
in beta alanine research so very very
prolific
uh very impactful career i i would
if i had to if you had a mount rushmore
of
sport nutrition researchers i don't see
how you could possibly leave roger off
of it
like he really pioneered the work on
both creatine
and beta alanine which just so happens
to be the two things that like kind of
work sometimes
which is pretty wild but anyway i bump
into him
and he's presenting these findings where
they were kind of mathematically
modeling what muscle carnosine
saturation
ought to look like you know if what we
know about
beta alanine and carnosine is true
they're like here's the math
mathematical model
and their basic premise was like we're
we're probably
under dosing beta alanine
in virtually all studies basically they
were they were saying if you could get
around
some of the annoying side effects to
allow higher daily doses
we could probably saturate human muscle
with far more carnosine
than we're seeing in a lot of the beta
alanine research
and you know the the pathway to doing
that is longer studies and higher daily
doses
but doses are usually constrained just
because it becomes so unpleasant to go
with really high doses
of beta-alanine so fast forward to like
last year i think there was a
meta-analysis by
it's it looks like it's resendy and
colleagues but i'm pretty sure
it's a brazilian group and ours are h's
sometimes in in portuguese so
hazendi maybe but uh anyway
they they did a meta-analysis looking at
muscle carnosine responses to various
beta-alanine doses
and they did some really really
fascinating modeling with their data
and they kind of came to the same
conclusion from a more
empirical direction and they're like
yeah
we can probably get muscle carnosine
levels much higher than we've seen in
previous research it's just going to be
a matter of
getting over some of the logistical
barriers so that's an
area that i'm excited to see develop
moving forward
it is plausible to suggest that we might
be
underestimating the utility of beta
alanine
and underestimating the effect size
because we're not really
increasing muscle carnosine to the
extent that is possible
so if people can continue to develop
ways to deliver beta-alanine with
circumventing the paresthesia and some
of the side effects of high doses
i'm thinking of you know the obvious uh
one of the obvious
routes to do that would be with some of
the sustained release formulas that that
people are working on
um but if people can find any other
creative way
to deliver beta alanine at higher doses
without some of those side effects
and the big ones like i said are
headache and and just that tingling
um i'm curious to see if the effect
sizes we observe
go up because you know what we find in
studies is that the
uh the magnitude of improvements does
tend to be related to the magnitude of
increase in muscle carnosine which is
very very intuitive so there's some
interesting
speculation uh based on good
evidence coming on the dosing side or
the loading side with muscle carnosine
levels
but there's also new research on the
washout side of things so if you
cease supplementation you know how long
does it take for muscle carnosine levels
to drop back down to baseline
can i just slide another quick question
in here
sure do you know if beta alanine is like
creatine
where it will spontaneously break down
in water
um you know the thing that's tricky
about that is there's just this
wonderful paper that just tackled
everything you'd want to know about
creatine's
properties and like how long it breaks
down in water and
how that changes when the ph changes and
the temperature changes
i don't know of such a paper for beta
alanine so
i'm not certain what its stability looks
like in water
uh obviously it's very stable in
powdered form but i'm not sure about
liquid form
yeah i saw i was just wondering because
you know it seems like they're trying a
bunch of
big brain solutions like hey we're gonna
mix it with anserine
we're gonna work on an extended release
formula
uh my my very room temperature iq
type idea was why not just mix it in a
lot of water
and just sip on it throughout the day so
you're never getting like
that large of a dose at any one time
well
would you even believe that that's what
i did when i first read this
meta-analysis
oh [ __ ] um and i'm here to tell the tale
uh i don't know what my muscle carnosine
levels were like
um but yeah that was that was my kind of
intuitive
genius mode solution was like oh what if
i just sipped on a lot of it
throughout the day and so yeah it could
be that by the end of the day i was just
sipping pure
toxins just absolute
caustic breakdown products who knows but
uh i'll look into that we'll have to
circle back next episode and
do some more digging on on some of these
beta alanine ideas
and maybe the listeners will have some
questions to add to the list yeah
because i mean
that's the first place my brain goes uh
obviously that would be difficult to
study because
you don't you don't trust human subjects
with that much anyways
uh if you ran a study where you're where
you were just like hey here's
some powder you put in water uh just mix
it in like a gallon of water and just
drink on it throughout the day and we're
just gonna have to trust that you drink
it all
and will accurately report whether you
did or not
i don't know that and drink it at the
right increments as well
yeah yeah correct yeah um yeah i i would
not
even if that study got published i
wouldn't put that much stock in it i
wouldn't believe them
after working with human research
subjects um
so yeah that would be tough to study but
i mean it might be a practical thing
in the real world if someone is you know
kind of obsessive about supplement
timing protocols
yeah i can't recommend that until we
figure out about the stability question
but but yeah it certainly was the first
thing that came to mind for me
uh but yeah i mean every now and then uh
you know i i try to be really mindful of
you know
when people volunteer for research uh
it's such a kind thing to do i mean
they're making a huge sacrifice
uh to benefit others you know so i i i
hate when people are like the creed song
exactly i don't know which creature my
sacrifice
yes i think that was about participating
in research it probably was
uh and by the way if you're a huge creed
head
like greg is there are videos of their
house
their their half-time performance at
um a thanksgiving day football game in
2001
at a cowboys game at a cowboys game yeah
on thanksgiving day
and it is one of the worst things
you could even imagine and i i actually
i showed it to you greg and then you
showed it to your wife
i lost my [ __ ] mind lindsay was
actually like upset
she was physically revulsed by it yeah
so
i'm i might have to dig up the link and
put in the show notes
oh that was so bad but uh
anyway what was oh yeah so research uh
research participants you know
you never want to like be too hard on
them because what they're doing is
ultimately
doing everybody out there a huge favor
um but yeah every now and then i'll look
at those papers where it's like yeah the
intervention was to take
two capsules two flavorless capsules a
day
and you you see the adherence rate was
like 88
and you're like what or like the
compliance and it's like
yeah if you can't get people to take two
capsules a day
yeah sipping on a a huge beverage
perfectly throughout the day probably
not going to happen
i mean that's like talking to um
physical therapists uh because
if you have an injury they'll often have
you go into physical therapy a few times
a week to do some exercises there
and you might be thinking like hey why
do i have to do this why can't i just do
these exercises at home
talking to physical therapists their
basic reason for that is like
because no one ever does the exercises
at home and it's like oh yeah just just
kick your knee a few times a day if
you want to be able to walk normally
again for the rest of your life and
people don't do that so i just don't
trust
subjects to take supplements that well
on their own
yeah so um we'll definitely look into
that stability question with beta
alanine but
um i did want to mention a lot of times
people ask me with
people who are supplementing with beta
alanine ask me
about you know i'm i stopped taking it
for a week or two
what what should i do about that how
much have have i missed out on
uh how much could my muscle carnosine
levels really drop over
a week or two of missed doses so i think
this was a really
helpful paper uh for answering that
question but also
you know if you're looking at a
crossover trial
and you know they had people do beta
alanine supplementation and then
then they have a washout period and then
they do the placebo intervention
you need to when you're evaluating that
research you need to make sure that the
washout period is sufficient
for muscle carnosine levels to get back
down to baseline
and so this study and i'll put the link
in the show notes obviously
looked at um you know they gave 6.4
grams a day of beta alanine a pretty
typical
dose uh over an eight week period so
pretty standard
and then they just watched muscle
carnosine levels fall over time
and the with this particular dosing
protocol it did follow a relatively
linear pattern
uh in terms of the the drop over time uh
you know it kind of flattened out a
little bit toward the end but
fairly linear in general and so
they saw drops occurring over about a 16
week period and by
by the time they got to week 16 i think
you could
roughly say that muscle carnosine levels
were pretty much back to baseline
they were still elevated the slightest
bit but they were pretty close by
week 16 but that that's pretty much my
answer for folks is you can expect a
reasonably linear drop for about 16
weeks and by week 16
you're pretty much back to baseline uh
roughly
so uh a lot of interesting stuff going
on right now in the beta alanine world
and the related
histidine containing dipeptides uh so i
just want to wrap this up with some
conclusions and
you know the practical stuff is a ways
off
just because this is kind of on the
forefront of the literature but
uh definitely keep these dosing and
washout considerations in mind when
you're looking at research
uh you know 6.4 grams a day for an 8-12
week period is the most common thing
you're going to see in research
if they're going below 6.4 it's possible
that they're they're
really underselling the potential
utility of beta alanine and
not really increasing muscle carnosine
levels as much as you'd like to see
and now we're learning that even the 6.4
you know could potentially be improved
upon
so it is possible that beta-alanine's
effect sizes are a little bit larger
than we currently
see in the literature but of course one
thing to keep in mind
is that it's going to be task specific
so
beta alanine if you're doing sprints
that last six minutes
absolutely like it's kind of a
no-brainer if you're doing sprints that
last
two or three minutes absolutely a lot of
times people who lift are like well
why would i use beta alanine if you're
doing
high load low repetition
uh efforts with plenty of rest between
sets probably not getting much of a
benefit
uh unless we see that with these really
high doses
there's something there but i wouldn't
hold my breath about that i'd say
that the people who stand to gain the
most in terms of lifters
from something like beta alanine if
you're a crossfitter
if you do strongman competitions if you
do
really high rep stuff uh with short rest
periods but which i actually do
sometimes you know sometimes if i'm
crunched for time
and i just want to get in for 45 minutes
and get a great hypertrophy stimulus
i do some sets of you know 12 to 20 and
i
have kind of shorter rest periods maybe
some super setting things like that
so i wouldn't be surprised to see that
you know there might be some benefit
there
a little bit speculative but the the
general point is that
you know the the the degree to which
you're stressing some of the
glycolytic energy system and the lactate
tolerance
you know those types of aspects of
physiology
the degree to which you're stressing
those things is probably going to
you know give you an idea of how much
you could expect to really gain
from beta alanine supplementation
another thing to keep in mind is that
we're talking about
these other histidine-containing
dipeptides for acute supplementation
trying to increase blood levels of them
i think a very fair
question would be why would i do that
instead of doing something like sodium
bicarbonate supplementation
which you know very effectively
facilitates buffering
uh and elevates blood levels of
bicarbonate
uh and the answer is i don't know i
think
if i had to pick one or the other based
on the evidence available
i i'd probably go with sodium bicarb
over a mixture of carnosine and anserine
but
you know i'm sure we're going to see
some some research in the next couple
years that puts that to the test and
says
uh you know group a elevated sodium
bicarbonate levels in the blood group b
elevated you know these
histidine-containing dipeptides and
and look at some of those acute effects
i would expect that sodium bicarbonate
is probably the more efficacious route
but i still think it's good to keep
an eye on this emerging research and see
how it develops also why not both
of course i mean i i put in the timeline
i've got it time stamped and everything
i say maybe use
use them in combination you know if
you're doing the type of exercise that
that
really benefits from facilitating those
buffering systems
i i do think that there's probably some
potential for
uh you know just kind of the you know
broad spectrum approach of saying i'm
going to take beta alanine chronically
and then acutely go with the combination
of these other histidine-containing
compounds and sodium bicarbonate
and with sodium bicarbonate several like
a million episodes ago i talked about a
unique strategy for
kind of titrating the dose and doing
small doses
and kind of a pattern building up so
that you don't have to take a huge dose
at once and run the risk of having some
extremely unpleasant uh gi symptoms so
uh i i wanna you know everyone's coming
out with these
ridiculous supplement blends every two
weeks
i think this is something that like if
you were thinking what's an
area where we actually could use a blend
rather than a single ingredient
approach and this is listen folks this
is free advice i'm not even charging for
this
someone's out there with a supplement
company dude
i mean you know a sensible dose of
sodium bicarbonate
with uh you know some carnosine some
anserine
that might not be a bad kind of you know
pre-exercise buffering thing for people
doing
you know really glycolytic activity you
should hit up bulk supplements
i don't think they do uh blended
products like that do
do they not do any at all they might i
don't know
i mean we've made them billions of
dollars at this point we could
potentially get a
uh eric trexler formulated bulk
supplements
buffer blend yeah absolutely they do
citrulline malate that is literally a
mixture of citrulline and malate
yeah but anyway uh so i think there are
some really interesting possibilities
looking at this research moving forward
so we'll see if any of it pans out but
uh really interesting stuff coming out
here and
of course another practical takeaway is
you know if you miss a few doses of beta
alanine don't sweat it
it's you know it's not going to just
tank from missing a couple days of
supplementation
it takes you know a couple weeks to even
see an appreciable drop that that would
even really register
um and in in terms of total washout
we're talking about a 16-week period
which is a long time
so i think that does it for uh
that was a long-winded look at some new
interesting stuff
on beta alanine i i've got another
question okay
um so th this could be
uh you you might be
uh refusing to answer this question via
rejecting the premise
just throwing that out there to start
with i read somewhere
and i don't remember where that
there were potentially issues with
long-term beta-alanine supplementation
because
it can have a competitive inhibitory
effect on taurine because they use the
same receptor
yeah um and that people were concerned
that
supplementing with beta-alanine could
decrease taurine levels
in the brain and testes which could
be bad for for brain health and
testicular health and function long term
do you know anything about that
yeah there there was a study within the
last couple years that that
specifically looked at that so they they
gave a pretty generous dose of beta
alanine
um and they looked at muscle levels
of of taurine and carnosine and things
like that
and uh you know i don't have the exact
numbers
off the top of my head but it largely
alleviated those concerns
um now big caveat it was only within the
kind of
typical framework of beta-alanine dosing
so if they do find ways to deliver
way higher doses then that seems like a
nice thing for muscle carnosine levels
but then they'll probably have to
revisit that and make sure
that they don't cross some kind of
dosing threshold where that taurine
issue becomes
more a more pressing issue
just to rule it out you know but but so
far within the typical
dosing approach it doesn't seem to be an
issue second caveat
like i said they looked at muscle
touring levels because
people don't seem to be really excited
about giving
biopsies from their brain or their
testes so
i'm assuming that the same is true for
those tissues but
i'd have to look into a lot more testy
physiology to ensure that we can
extrapolate that from muscle
to to those other tissues but uh i know
a lot of people have been worried about
muscle touring levels with beta alanine
and
those concerns have been largely
alleviated within the dosing
strategies that we see commonly applied
cool
all right you want to talk about some of
your research
uh not that you did it but you found it
yeah yeah so
uh research roundup time yes cool so
i've got
i didn't count maybe a half dozen papers
give or take
and uh just gonna run down them real
quick uh so the first one i want to talk
about
is by moquin and colleagues uh
title is lean body mass and muscle
cross-sectional area adaptations
among college-age males with different
strength levels across
11 weeks of block periodized program
resistance training oh that's a mouthful
um but yeah anyway so i i wanted to talk
about this study very briefly
because an idea or a question that i get
pretty frequently
is um basically to what degree
does hypertrophy and strength blocks
feed into each other so one of the
things that
i'll admit the evidence like the direct
experimental evidence for isn't super
strong but one of the things that i do
believe to be true
is that uh muscle hypertrophy increases
your potential for strength gains
and so you know if you're if you're
hitting a pretty hard
wall uh you're plateaued really hard
might not be a terrible idea to do a
fairly prolonged period of hypertrophy
training
so you can build some more muscle which
can then increase your propensity for
strength gains
one of the questions that that i
frequently feel is basically does that
work in reverse
if you've hit a muscle plateau can
increasing your strength levels um
you know and theoretically here we're
we're primarily talking about things
like neural adaptations basically
getting
more contractile force out of your
current amount of muscle mass
can that then help you break through
that muscle plateau
to allow for greater hypertrophy
um and i don't think
that exists i i don't think there's
particularly great evidence for it
and i'm not aware of a particularly
sound theoretical rationale for it
and this paper by moquin i think
indirectly speaks to this a little bit
um so they they took uh
groups of people who had some prior
training experience
the exact amount of training experience
for each group
uh isn't reported unfortunate
unfortunately
uh but they split them into three groups
based on their
squatting ability in terms of squat 1rm
per unit of body mass so the people
classified
as low strength squatters squatted less
than 1.25 times body mass
the people classified as medium strength
squatters squatted between 1.25 and 1.75
times body mass
and the people classified as high
strength squatters
uh squatted more than 1.7 times body
mass
they did 11 weeks of training and they
looked to see
changes in both lean body mass and also
vastus lateralis cross-sectional area
pre to post training
i'm not going to talk about the low
strength squatters
one because i i suspect they just had
considerably lower training status and
two because they had
a pretty fair bit less lean mass than
than the moderate and high strength
squatters did um
but i i did think the comparison between
the moderate and high strength squatters
was pretty interesting
so the moderate strength squatters
were uh at least a bit bigger than the
high strength squatters so they had
more lean body mass and a
non-significantly greater
vastus lateralis cross-sectional area at
baseline so basically
they they had more muscle but they were
weaker
and so theoretically if having more
muscle
or if having more strength per unit of
muscle
potentiates future hypertrophy one would
have
expected quite a bit larger or quite a
bit more hypertrophy in the high
strength squatters in this study
and that's now what they found all three
groups
experienced pretty similar increases in
uh fastest lateralis cross-sectional
area
pretty similar increases in lean body
mass they also had a metric that was
lean body mass
corrected for total body water and those
increases did not significantly differ
between groups either
and if anything there was maybe a slight
trend for that corrected lean body mass
metric to increase a little bit more in
the moderate strength squatters and the
highest
than the high strength squatters which
would run counter to the theory
of being stronger per unit of muscle
mass
potentiating future hypertrophy uh to be
clear this
this isn't like a slam dunk case against
that idea that building strength will
uh help with muscle one because sample
size was
was low uh two uh not to be too nitpicky
here i'm not crazy about the
statistical approach the authors used um
they had 15 total subjects and they
split them into three groups and ran
a five by three anova so three groups
five time points
uh they should have just used regression
uh that would have preserved a lot more
statistical power so if they were going
to have any significant findings that
would have made it
quite a bit easier to find those things
well and it's not even just the
statistical power thing but it's just a
it would be a statistical test that is
more consistent with the question being
asked oh for sure
you know for sure that's the thing that
that gets me is
you get a lot of this where people ought
to have used correlation or regression
and they say well
i usually use anova in my studies so
let's go ahead and group this up
you also see several hundred
million examples of people who should
have used something like
logistic regression in our field and and
they just don't
uh but yeah i don't want to get in a
whole rant about it but yeah
i i agree with you yeah that's that's
all i was gonna say about it and the
the third caveat here um is that we
don't
know what the training backgrounds
looked like for these people
so you know it could be that there were
considerable differences in training
status between the moderate strength
squatters and the high strength
squatters here
uh and maybe the higher the moderate
strength squatters
were just like genetically predisposed
to hypertrophy more
but maybe had trained a little bit less
and so that's how they wound up
uh with lower squat strength but greater
lean body mass so you know
you don't want to over extrapolate from
a study with a small sample size but i i
do think this
is indirect evidence against that idea
that
building strength and achieving greater
strength per unit of muscle mass
will help you break through hypertrophy
plateaus i i think the
strength to size relationship works in
the direction of building more size can
help you build more strength i don't
think building more strength
necessarily helps you therefore in the
future build more muscle
uh did you have something else to say no
uh
kind of i was going to say i agree uh
with your assessment of the evidence
um but but you know one thing to keep in
mind is
uh from a practical perspective yeah if
you do coach people you
you train people and their goals are
mostly hypertrophy focused
um when they there is some
value to enjoying the process of
strength gains and seeing the weight on
the bar go up over time just from the
subjective experience of the fitness
journey so
i i think even if you've got a client
who's maybe 90
90 focused on hypertrophy and just 10
gets a kick out of getting stronger you
know it's not like these results
indicate you can't do
more strength focused blocks oh yeah you
know it's still nice to throw them in
there for some variety to keep things
fresh to
to like i said to enjoy the process of
seeing the weight on the bar go up it's
you know but but well and i also think
that as a result
of effective hypertrophy training now
you have more contractile tissue the
loads on the bar
should naturally increase from there
yeah i i just would hate to see someone
who
is a trainer or coach who hears those
findings and goes
all right no one's going under eight you
know eight reps per set
yeah yeah ever again so no i'm talking
about it more from kind of like uh
like a i'm plateaued and i need to
troubleshoot this type perspective like
if you know if you've been doing
hypertrophy training
and you haven't really been gaining much
muscle and you're like okay
i need to try something else to get
things moving again
um i feel like i might be a little bit
weak
per the amount of muscle that i have on
my frame
so what should i do should i try some
other generally effective approach to
hypertrophy training or
should i do you know a 12-week block of
heavy doubles to really try to
increase my squat bench deadlift max and
that'll help me build more muscle
all i'm saying is like if that's kind of
the the
thought process you're going through you
probably want to go with some other
general approach to hypertrophy training
yeah and if nothing else
else works just throw some chains on the
bar and it'll be fun
hell yeah yeah all right uh moving on
this this next one is
it's gonna be i guess more of a shout
out to a paper than
talking about it in depth mostly because
this is a
uh pretty like biomechanics focused
paper which
doesn't lend itself that well to an
audio medium
but steven larson who uh connected with
on social media seems like a great guy
um currently a phd student
i believe uh he's been doing some really
really cool
uh work looking at the sticking points
in both the squat and the bench press i
think i recently have reviewed
like three of his studies in the last
six months in mass
this one i'm not going to be reviewing
in mass i don't think but it was a
really cool study the title is new
insights about the sticking region in
back squats
an analysis of kinematics kinetics and
myoelectric activity around the sticking
region
and the biggest reason i wanted to talk
about this paper and just kind of shout
it out
is this is the first paper i've seen
that looks at the sticking point
or the sticking region in an exercise
that includes
the right metrics to look at you know
why do people start decelerating and
struggle to get through the sticking
region
so uh the
the way a lot of these papers are set up
is basically they'll look
at um kinetics kinematics
and sometimes emg at four different time
points in a lift
so they'll look at it at the start of
the concentric phase
at the point of first peak velocity so
you know in a squat
you squat down you start coming back up
the bar starts moving
it accelerates in the upward direction
and then it slows down
and then you hit a point of minimum
concentric velocity
there near the end of your sticking
region and then once you break through
that
you know you're you're going to be able
to stand up with it as long as you don't
lose your balance
so at some point you hit a point of
second uh
peak velocity and then the bar has to
decelerate again
before lockout so those are the four
points they look at
start of the concentric first peak
concentric velocity
minimum concentric velocity and second
peak concentric velocity but none of
those are the most important part
uh in the concentric phase of a lift
that you're grinding
grinding through the most important part
is the point of peak deceleration
that's going to occur after that first
peak in velocity
but before minimum bar velocity so force
is mass times acceleration
and so when the bar is decelerating at
its peak rate
that is the point at which you're
applying the least amount of force to
the bar
that's why it's decelerating at its
maximal rate
so if you're interested in investigating
you know
what gets hard about a lift why are
people failing
where they fail what's contributing to
that that is really
the the time point that you you want to
be able to focus in on because that's
that's where the wheels start falling
off that is where where people are
producing the least amount of positive
concentric force
um and so uh steven
was uh the first person i've seen who's
who's actually documented that uh in any
of the power lifts
in research so so props to him for the
paper
uh and then also just to talk about the
findings a little bit
uh basically they they took people who
had
uh prior squat experience i think worked
them up to
a a three rep max squat
uh and then looked to see kinetics
kinematics emg
on the last rep where they were
you know really grinding pretty hard uh
and and they basically found that
from from the the point of
first peak velocity to the point of
minimum bar velocity so basically that
that defines the beginning
and end of the sticking region what you
basically see in the squat is just the
whole thing getting
more and more hip dominant both the
kinematics so
you know joint angles segments position
in space
so both the kinematics and emg findings
bear that out
so basically you see relatively flat
quad emg from the start of the
concentric to the
end of the sticking region you see
ramping up
uh emg levels for the hip extensors so
they looked at the
the hamstrings and the glutes um and
they they also
looked at so they calculated a metric
that was
the total uh like the sum of the joint
moments present
and then what percentage of that was
being contributed by the hip extensors
what percentage of that was being
contributed by the knee extensors what
percentage of that was being contributed
by
uh which one's plantar flexion which
which one's dorsiflexion dorsiflexion is
toes pointed towards the ground right
plantar flexion here's the way i always
i i always
i always forget that one minor flexion
is when you point your toe
and dorsiflexion is when you dig your
heel in okay
okay that's what i felt uh so yeah also
plantar flexion
uh contribution to the totality of joint
moments
and so what you see is throughout the
sticking region
basically the relative contribution of
the hips is going up
relative contribution of the calves
basically flat and relative contribution
of the quads going down
um so that i mean that's
i i think something that most people
kind of intuit that's something i've
been talking about forever
um and one of the things you can see
is the the total uh
knee extension moment that the quads are
producing
um is going down pretty precipitously as
the concentric starts and it's quite low
by the end of the sticking region
one of the cues i've been giving forever
or one of the pieces of advice
is that to get through the sticking
region of the squat
one of the things that helps a lot is
you want to get your
knees forward and your hips back under
the bar very much
seems like when people fail a squat it's
because
basically the hip extension moment or
the hip flexion moment created by the
bar is greater than their hip extensors
can overcome
and you kind of wind up with a reserve
of what the quads are capable of doing
by the time you get to the end of the
sticking region so basically
um you know your your quads
or your knees tend to shift back a
little bit as you start the concentric
your quads are doing about all they can
out of the hole but then
as you near the end of the sticking
region generally
at that point your quads have a bit more
juice
than they are at that point capable of
contributing to the squat
just because your knees have gotten out
of position they've shifted back a
little bit too far
so if you can just tick your knees
forward half an inch
that tends to be all it takes for most
people
to uh get the bar moving again and break
through the sticking region so that's
uh it it kind of looks like a hip scoop
almost like
like the second pull of a clean uh if
you've watched much weight lifting um
anyway cool paper and for other
researchers out there
if you want to look into the sticking
region of really any lift
document what's going on at the point of
peak deceleration because that that
really is
uh the weakest point in the lift and you
know that's
that's a good place to have information
about can i ask you a
deeply personal question sure
so i have noticed that you you've
reviewed
a lot of this researchers papers lately
and every now and then i think about
like if if somebody just gave me the
keys to a lab and said
eric you're a professional researcher
now you know i
i sometimes think about like okay what
would i do you know what would my major
lines of research be uh
so if you had to pick is he like your
your research avatar is he doing what
you would be doing
in that scenario if you just had the
keys to a lab and were free to
study what interested you or is there
someone else out there doing more
more stuff that's in line with who you
would be
i'd probably do training studies yeah i
mean
in the real world i wouldn't because
that's a lot of work
but but in terms of uh
what i think probably offers the most
value that if if i were a better person
what would i do
probably that yeah i i think um
now this is out of character because i
hate when people
you know kind of play the card of you
know you don't have enough
experience to have an opinion on
something but i do think anyone that's
harshly critical of training studies uh
especially if it's without justifiable
uh you know without good reasoning for
being so critical it's like
you really ought to run a training study
and just
live in the pain that is running a
training study before you get
too many hot takes about them because
they like you said they are
they are brutal so huge tip of the cap
to everyone out there running training
studies because we need them
but man it's it's a tough it's a tough
job to have for sure
absolutely uh okay moving on
a paper by cuthbert and colleagues
looking at
it's a training frequency meta-analysis
so the title is
effects of variation in resistance
training frequency on strength
development
in well-trained populations and
implications for in-season athlete
training
a systematic review and meta-analysis uh
so this is going to be very quick
i used to be a pretty big proponent of
higher training frequencies both for
for hypertrophy and strength development
um
previously that was the direction the
research was
leaning but as more papers have been
published and especially more papers
in well-trained cohorts we're seeing
that especially
in in folks with prior training
experience
it doesn't seem like frequency has all
that large of an effect if any effect at
all
so this meta-analysis included
10 studies with trained subjects looking
to see whether higher or lower training
frequencies
had a differential impact on both upper
and lower body strength development
found that it didn't
the frequencies represented by these
studies spanned all the way from
one session per lift per week up to nine
sessions per lift per week
uh which is very high um
and yeah we've found that frequency as
long as volume is equated frequency
doesn't seem to have
much of an impact on strength
development i will say
that um i i do still think that the
research in this area is somewhat
limited by practical constraints
so you know for example um
if your ideal weekly volume
for a given lift or given muscle group
is quite high
that may simply not be doable in a
single training session
um i i kind of think the positive
benefits you accrue
per set uh decreases over the course
of a session such that you know if
you're doing
uh like five sets versus 20 sets
i think what you're getting out of the
first set is probably
the greatest of any set and what you're
getting out of the fifth set like the
marginal
benefits you get from that fifth set
probably greater than the marginal
benefits you'd get from a 20th set
and so over kind of like low to moderate
weekly training volumes
you know that that seems to come out in
the wash but if you're someone who does
just tend to respond better to higher
total
weekly training volumes uh you know that
may still lend itself to higher
frequencies and i
i think that if you're someone who for
whatever reason maybe you've just found
it works best for you maybe you just
like it
uh you know you're gonna be training
with high volumes
i'd much rather do eight sets of squats
three times a week than
24 sets of squats in one session most
people don't need that level of volume
in the first place but so
basically what i'm getting at is is i do
think that there are still
practical reasons someone may favor
higher training frequencies either for
themselves or their clients
uh but again especially for fairly low
to moderate
uh total weekly training volumes
doesn't really seem like frequency has
that much of an impact on strength gains
uh in trained lifters awesome good stuff
all right i have three more i'm going to
talk about
these three are going to be very quick
uh this next one is more of just a shout
out than a review of a paper
um so the the title of this paper is
history of
strength training research and man an
inventory and
quantitative overview of studies
published in english
between 1894 and 1979
by nuzzo so this is an open access paper
and if you're someone who is interested
in the history of strength research
this is the thing to check out uh it is
incredibly in-depth it's super long has
almost 400 references and it's just
documenting
trends in strength research from 1894 to
1979.
um i i'm personally going to refer back
to this paper when
so i've been planning on writing
something about isometrics for a while
and one of the issues i've run into is i
knew that
there was a lot of research on
isometrics back in the 60s and 70s
but like databases like pubmed
don't don't index older journals and
older studies
quite as well as more recent stuff like
uh the
the databases that you'd search they get
a little bit spottier as you go further
and further back in time so i had a hard
time
uh wrangling up those references that i
knew to exist
but anyway they're all in this they're
all cited in this paper
um and that that's the case for all of
this
old school strength research um so so
this is
quite frankly a staggering work of
documentation
um personally the thing that jumped out
to me the most
that uh just in terms of how things have
changed over time
was there was a little bit uh looking at
authorship
and how many papers people used to
publish and how many authors used to be
on each paper
um so richard berger
was the leader over this time period
with the most first author or
soul author publications with 12
uh which you know
what would you say trex that would be
like a pretty impressive like phd
campaign these days
well you know so sorry are
are these studies all longitudinal
training interventions
um i don't think they were
because yeah i mean if it was if you
include things like you know little
supplement studies here
cross-sectional strength evaluations
there then yes
absolutely uh you know for sure i think
that would be accurate
um but yeah i mean
to your point uh 12
for a career i mean i mean yeah if
you're applying for tenure
and you've got 12 these days you're
probably you're probably sweating
depending on what what institution
you're at yeah it
it may have just been longitudinal
studies but even
even then like if if that's something
you do 12 over the course of a training
career
yeah um which to be clear
i'm not necessarily duncan on that one
of the one of the themes we come back to
on the podcast all the time is that um
i i think a lot of science that gets
done
i'm not i'm not trying to be too
critical i think a lot of things that
that get done might get done to pad cvs
more than answer a question as well as
possible
and so you know there there is a world
and i think it is this world
where 12 really well done training
studies could provide a lot more value
than
50 kind of normal training studies yeah
yeah the um the interest here is is not
in comparing
errors uh but more just observing the
trend and
looking at like you know i agree with
you i mean if someone said hey
looking back at my career i did 12
incredible papers or i did
you know 31 that were pretty shoddy
because i had you know
professional uh benchmarks to meet
give me the 12 every time you know but
yeah it is interesting to see how the
business of being a scientist has
changed
yeah so uh number one on the list
richard berger with 12.
uh next was philip rash with nine uh and
then
it was six and fewer for everyone else
over this
almost hundred year period one of the
names that jumped out
uh honestly feel bad for the guy carl
klein
uh if you're listening to the podcast
i'm sure he is
i feel for you buddy um so he he
published six papers
uh the third most prolific uh
publisher of strength training research
of this area
uh pioneering work and strength training
for knee rehab
published six papers that got a total of
five citations on them
which honestly that's kind of wild to me
because that i mean that's a big deal
if you look at really any like rehab
literature
resistance training type stuff to to
restore function after injury that's i
mean
that's where the field is you know yeah
and
uh so klein was one of the pioneers
there and apparently
his papers just never got sighted which
it's very sad very bad
it's almost like uh those artists that
you hear about that never enjoyed fame
during their lifetime but then like
become wildly popular way later well i
mean his papers still aren't getting
cited i know but
but i mean just the idea that like a
long time ago he was like ah
knee rehab maybe you should lift it
would be like if someone else
invented cubism and then picasso said
like
hey this is cool i'm gonna do this and
then no one ever heard about the guy
that
actually started it yeah that that is a
more direct analogy
um but yeah anyway we we appreciate carl
any of these contributions shout outs to
carl klein uh
one of the other trends with authorship
that i thought was
was kind of wild was uh the shift in
number of authors per paper and this is
one where i'm going to take a more
direct shot
uh if you so
if you're an author on a paper one of
the things that you have to certify
is basically that you made a pretty
large contribution to the paper in
conception analyzing the data
i don't even think you're supposed to be
on a paper just for collecting the data
um like it's it's you know there has to
be some sort of
pretty substantial intellectual
contribution to the work
being done and i don't know
some some papers that are out there
where there's there's some really heady
[ __ ] going on like
i don't know maybe you need 12 folks to
really
hash out all the details think through
everything
uh but i mean i don't know there's
there's a lot of papers getting
published that you see have like
a dozen authors and i mean most of them
are probably just the grad students that
collected the studies
and you know they probably need those
pubs on their cvs to
have a good chance of getting a job
getting into a phd program but
uh i don't think that meets the spirit
of those authorship requirements but
anyway when you go back and look at
these older papers
uh almost 45 of them were single author
papers
and fewer than five percent had five
plus authors
and uh yeah just compare that to
the sheer author counts on studies
getting published these days
uh pretty pretty stark difference and i
mean
a lot of that is just norms shifting
over time
um but i i do think that it's
i don't know i i think that it creates a
bit of an unlevel playing field where if
you
uh say work with an advisor that has
more of kind of like
an old school traditional view of
authorship you know they may be less
likely to put you on a type of paper for
or put you on a paper for the same type
of contribution that
someone else has gotten their name on a
dozen papers for
um so yeah i think that a single
standard is probably ideal
and you know i'm not necessarily averse
to
more lacks authorship requirements so
such that
people who do you know still have their
hands saying like data collection
get some recognition for it help build
up their cv but
the fact that it does differ so much
place to place i think is probably less
than ideal
um and it is definitely a
big big shift that has occurred over
time
yeah you do not see a lot of single
author papers these days unless they're
like
a narrative review yeah you know you see
plenty of those but
outside of that you do not see a lot of
that anymore
yeah anyway so that that was a really
cool paper and if you're interested in
the history of strength training
research
you should check it out uh all right
next one
by steel and colleagues our boy pack
was an author on this paper i assume he
made a very large intellectual
contribution to it
uh title is the impact of coronavirus
parentheses code 19 related public
health measures on training behaviors of
individuals previously participating in
resistance training
a cross-sectional survey study uh so
basically what what this paper was doing
uh just a survey sent out to a lot of
folks said like hey if you were
previously lifting before
are you still doing some training if so
how's that training changed what did it
look like before what does it look like
now
uh but you know i mostly just wanted to
pull a very positive
nugget out of this study i was concerned
that when jim shut down a lot of people
who
you know are really into the barbell
would say like ah
[ __ ] it like if i can't get under a
heavy bar like
it's just not worth it i'm just not that
into it
but apparently 83 percent of people who
were
training before continued training
mostly just started lifting at home
did body weight training higher higher
rep stuff
uh probably a lot of them set up home
gyms to
facilitate more or less normal training
uh but yeah
yeah 83 so about six in
is that six and seven five and six
whatever a
hefty majority of people who were
training before
uh continued to keep training pretty
consistently
after gym shutdown so that's a very very
positive thing in my book
very positive not surprising uh
from my perspective as someone who had a
full roster of clients
um at the exact moment when the entire
world shut down
because like for a while at the
beginning of everything we were planning
for the apocalypse
yes the the coaching apocalypse yes um
but yeah so like for a while i don't i
don't think well
for a while i'm certain that people
didn't appreciate the broad
impact that kovid was gonna have it
seemed like something that was
isolated and then it seemed like in an
instant the entire world
said oh we're all going to be impacted
here
and you know i had clients at the time
spanning several continents
and it seemed like everybody in an
instant shut down
and like my entire roster of clients
used to train in the gym and as of like
that day
no longer had access and i was like
okay let's see what's gonna happen here
and i you know of course had that same
thought that a lot of people are gonna
think if i can't get into the gym under
a heavy
heavy barbell i'm not that into it
anymore um but but i was really
impressed by
uh the resiliency in it all my clients
who said all right i've got um
one rubber band and a 35 pound dumbbell
what do you got for me
and i know i know a lot of people that
were coaching at the time online
coaching
who uh there was like a a one week
period there where you had the
uh the tall task of converting every
single one of your clients on your
roster
to a completely customized program to
whatever the hell they had access to
but but yeah in that scenario i was so
impressed by the number of people who
said all right let's keep going and
figure this thing out
and so uh before that experience i would
have been shocked to see 83
but after that experience 83 sounds very
correct
i mean i honestly i i felt that that was
probably just selection bias like
you know the folks who are willing to
pay for a coach might be
a bit more invested in the whole
resistance training process than
the typical person true um and so
one of the things that i've been
interfacing with a lot is the
subreddit for people who've bought the
stronger by science programs
and there have been quite a few threads
of people being like oh yeah
gyms are opening back up uh you know
first
month of lockdown i did some some
push-ups and
some table rows but if i'm being honest
i haven't done anything in the last
like four months um so i i was
i didn't know how representative that
was but i
thought that that might apply to more
than one in seven people
yeah that's a good point um but yeah so
so 83 percent of people sticking with it
pretty good uh and and better than i
expected
obviously uh and then the last uh
paper gonna talk about in my research
roundup uh
effects of non-nutritive sweeteners on
body weight and bmi
in diverse clinical contexts a
systematic review and meta-analysis
um so you know not gonna talk about this
one in a ton of depth they did
a lot of sub analyses that i'm not going
to get into
but this was a meta-analysis looking at
studies that lasted for at least four
weeks so they they all had a
longitudinal component
uh where people were either given a
non-nutritive sweetener or
in other words an artificial sweetener
versus sugar
no intervention or water and they wanted
to see the impact
that a non-nutritive sweetener would
have on body weight and bmi
compared to those other interventions so
when they split things out a little so
in the main meta-analysis they just
looked at
non-nutritive sweeteners versus
everything else
found that it did have a small positive
impact on body weight so either larger
decreases in body weight or smaller
increases in body weight
then they split that out further and
basically look to see non-nutritive
sweeteners compared to water
compared to no intervention and compared
to sugar
and basically the impact of
non-nutritive sweeteners was
not statistically different from either
no intervention or
water meaning that you know compared to
things that don't have calories
sweeteners that don't have calories
don't seem to have a differential impact
on body weight or bmi compared to sugar
non-nutritive sweeteners did have uh
were associated with a decrease in
either
greater losses in body weight or smaller
increases in body weight
uh compared to sucrose one thing to note
though
about this meta-analysis it it said it
was a meta-analysis of non-nutritive
sweeteners
it was a meta-analysis of aspartame
because
pretty much all pretty much all
non-nutritive sweetener research is on
aspartame
my favorite i'm a big sucralose stan uh
splenda is the brand name
you're not gonna catch me buying splenda
because you can buy the walmart brand
for cheaper
it's just as good but anyway i'm a big
sucralose head
as it were there was only one sucralose
study included
in this meta-analysis and it actually
had the largest positive effect size
so when compared to sucrose
um sucralose was associated with the
largest uh either decrease or smaller
increase in
body weight observed in the entire
meta-analysis so i'm going to take that
one study to the bank
uh and just assume sucralose is
exceptionally good even when compared to
other non-nutritive sweeteners
even though it is nowhere close to time
to make
uh that sort of conclusion but anyway
scientific principles be damned
correct confirmation bias is truly
delightful correct
absolutely but yeah so uh you know
if you don't like artificial sweeteners
no one's making you use them
if you find that artificial sweeteners
are nice
you have a sweet tooth they help with
dietary adherence
um one of the claims that i frequently
see people
make is that like oh yeah like
artificial sweeteners they're better
than sugar but
you know if you're trying to lose weight
you're better with sticking with just
water uh when compared to say maybe
adding some splenda to your coffee
there doesn't seem to be strong evidence
for that water and
artificial sweeteners in longitudinal
set
studies seem to have similar impacts on
body weight
and artificial sweeteners as they are
intended to do
have a positive impact compared to sugar
so
you know if there's something that
you're
typically sweetening with sugar that
artificial sweeteners
can be subbed in with and you're trying
to lose weight uh
you know that's a that's a sensible
substitution to make
and this meta-analysis suggests that
these artificial sweeteners
do do what they are supposed to do and
help people lose weight
yeah people beat up on artificial
sweeteners and it's it's largely
unjustified you know people have
concerns
uh about things like uh glycemic control
or or compensatory eating behavior
compensatory eating behavior yeah i
think
people um i think people trick
themselves into believing that our
their body is far more poorly regulated
than it truly is
you know like oh man if there's
something sweet and not a
load of like 30 grams of glucose
following it
my body is just gonna freak out and it's
like no your
your body will be all right like it will
continue to manage your glycemic
responses very effectively
uh same thing you know oh if i sense
that sweetness but there's not you know
200 calories with it i will seek those
200 calories to make it right
and again like thank god we don't have
to manage our body with that level of
precision well
and there is some uh acute research
suggesting that that might happen to
some degree
but then but the the fact that we're
we're seeing
longitudinal decreases in weight and bmi
in you know studies that are lasting
four plus weeks rather than one
afternoon
suggests that you know if that happens
the first time you use a non-nutritive
sweetener
that's not a compensatory behavior
probably that continues long term
and the magnitude of those you know
there have been some individual studies
looking at like
some type of a glycemic response but not
as if there was
you know a huge perturbation or some
degree of compensation with a single
meal but
a lot of times you'll hear people uh
kind of asserting oh you you start using
these artificial sweeteners you start
overeating
all over all other aspects of your diet
all of a sudden you're gaining weight
because of the artificial sweetener
those types of concerns just simply
don't bear out in the research that's
done
all right moving on let's do it so
i am going to move on to the coach's
corner segment for a quick little
uh practical tip that uh relates to
something i've been training through uh
then we'll probably have time for
maybe a couple q a questions and then
we'll be
wrapping things up for the day so in the
coaches corner so
i'm back into the gym which i'm stoked
about
really happy to have all the different
exercise selection all the different
equipment
back on the menu it's been pretty
exciting
but of course you know same old body so
a couple issues that i often train
through i've got a pretty angry
right shoulder my biceps tendon tends to
get really inflamed coming up through
the shoulder
um i think it's because back i've got an
old football injury where i separated
the ac
joint and i broke the collarbone and
then i played a baseball tournament like
three weeks later
uh like that's my throwing arm so it
just never really healed right because
i was stubborn and really like playing
baseball
so uh lingering shoulder issues but i've
also got an issue with that elbow
i get some of that clicking with that
tendon down in the elbow you know what
i'm talking about
yeah uh not very fun and if if i'm not
mindful of it it can cause some
discomfort so
one of the reasons i wanted to discuss
this is because it's a two-pronged
issue that relates to pressing and so i
know a lot of people have pressing
issues whether it relates to
an old wrist injury an old elbow injury
an old shoulder injury or they just want
to modify their pressing to
uh to make sure they're circumventing uh
anything from like that from developing
over time any kind of
pain or discomfort or dysfunction so
i've been getting pretty creative with
my pressing and wanted to share some of
the uh
the things that have been helping me
thinking that maybe it'll help some
other people out there as well
so for me with the combined shoulder and
elbow issue
one of the things i have to be really
conscious of
is kind of my wrist angle or the way
that i'm
actually holding the implement on
lifting whether it's a barbell which
kind of insists upon a specific wrist
angle
or dumbbells that have a lot more
flexibility or different machine work so
i've been working with different angles
at which i'm holding my weights or kind
of setting my push-up grip
and i've also been very conscious of
range of motion with my shoulder
so range of motion of course you know a
simple way to reduce your range of
motion on the shoulder
is to just cut your reps a little
shorter on the eccentric but also
you can mess around with different
angles of pressing and see what angles
just feel better for your shoulder and
prevent some of that
irritation of the biceps tendon so
things that have been working really
well for me and things that it might be
worth giving a try if you're
trying to troubleshoot shoulder and
elbow issues
low and high incline presses with
dumbbells have been incredible
like i said the dumbbells give you a lot
of flexibility
in terms of how you're gripping you can
kind of turn it into more of like a
neutral
grip press rather than having uh you
know your thumbs kind of pointed in
toward each other like with a barbell
uh and the low and high incline give a
little bit of variety and it's it's the
flat pressing that
really has a bit of an extreme
angle for my shoulder that causes some
irritation so
incline smith presses have been great as
well um
and when the incline smith presses
aren't working or if i want to get kind
of a flatter pressing angle
i'll do kind of like a fake board press
where
a lot of smith machines you can build in
a kind of a safety or a stop mechanism
at a certain point in the range of
motion so i've been doing a lot of flat
and inclined smith pressing
smith machine presses but i've been
stopping my reps you know
maybe three inches off of the chest or
something like that
uh reduced range of motion push-ups with
dumbbell grips
so like i said a traditional push-up
grip can be tough on my
elbow also can be kind of tough on your
wrist so
using dumbbells as kind of a grip
for the you know you put the dumbbells
on the ground if they're flat enough for
it and just holding those
that's been really helpful for me allows
me to do
kind of halfway between a standard
push-up grip and like a like a neutral
grip push-up
uh so that's been helpful but also
putting a couple little
one or two little yoga blocks on the
ground where i
i touch my chest to them that's allowed
me to also adjust my range of motion on
those push-ups so
unfortunately i have to do like a ton of
push-ups when i shorten up the range of
motion but
it's still been a really nice uh it's
kind of a cool variation of the push-up
because
the more neutral grip combined with uh
the the shortened up range of motion it
allows me to really
isolate the pecs i almost feel like i
have this like it's kind of halfway
between a fly movement and
a pressing movement which is pretty cool
just focusing on kind of
almost feeling like you're trying to
drag those dumbbells together to meet
each other even though they're not
actually moving
and then of course cable crossovers are
a classic
they give you all the freedom in the
world when it comes to
your angle and your range of motion and
then finally
single arm medicine ball push-ups so
having one hand on the ground the other
on a medicine ball
gives you the the opportunity to do a
really nice
loaded stretch of the pec uh you know
if you've got your right hand on the
medicine ball such a great stretch for
that pec
and you can really adjust the range of
motion side to side so
you can get to the longest or largest
comfortable range of motion with one
side
and similar similarly do it the same
with the other side
and you can kind of tailor it to how
each shoulder is feeling so
that's just a quick run down of you know
as i've been trying to troubleshoot uh
multifactorial pressing issues those are
things that have really been
bailing me out of what would otherwise
be a bit of a jam
with my pressing exercises so
you want to move on and do some uh some
q
a questions yeah yeah let's let's do
some quick q a so i'm gonna go with the
uh
the top two solicited from reddit and
facebook
uh so this first one i think is for both
of us
um smile missile on reddit
asks uh what is the most bum [ __ ]
ludicrous programming or workout you've
ever
heard of or seen with your own eyes so
the example he gave is someone doing
[Music]
10 sets of six reps 500 pound
ass to grass front squats then following
it up with deadlifts and cleans
seemed very strong um
whatever so that is i took it more
the answer i have in mind i took it more
as like
not what is the most impressive workout
you've seen but just what is the
stupidest workout you've seen
that that was my impression when you
read it out yeah yeah so let's uh
let's go with that do you do you have
any in mind
um i don't know the exact numbers like
i i hadn't seen this question ahead of
time to look them up or anything
but um you know the easiest answers that
come to mind
are it used to be very fashionable
in american collegiate football for the
strength coaches to like just do
a workout that would give i don't know
11 team
teammates rhabdo and so yeah and just
all of those pretty much um like yeah
it used to be that like once a summer
like every summer
uh when they're coming in for their big
camps it's like oh okay all my athletes
are d-trained because they didn't do
stuff at home
and yeah let's bring them in and just do
something that's completely inadvisable
and 11 of them will go to the hospital
and i will do my best not to get fired
uh i think that's becoming less
fashionable or at least i hope
but yeah i mean there's all those
news stories are out there for anyone
interested in the details
i will say one of the stupidest things
i've ever done uh
was so like like every
uh young person i think i did small lob
junior for bench
and it worked quite well it turns out if
you bench heavy a lot and you don't get
hurt your bench goes up a lot it's
pretty great
and then i did small of a bass mesocycle
for squats
and i was like hey that also worked for
the similar
principles i just outlined and then at
one point i was like
i'm just gonna do them both at the same
time you know like
i'm in a hurry i need to get big and
strong i'm just going to do
small of junior on bench and the base
mesocycle of small of for squat
but do them like an inverted uh schedule
so that my ten sets of three on bench
are my fewer sets for squat and then by
the end of the week when i'm doing my 10
sets of three on the squat i've got only
a few sets of bench i think it's like
six by six
uh dumb for just hundreds
if not thousands of reasons uh but yeah
that was pretty dumb
all right so i i can one-up you this is
uh this is really bad
so i'm going to uh give as few details
as possible just so people can't go back
and try to
to reconstruct who this person is but i
had a buddy
that played high school in baseball or
uh that played baseball in high school
and they had a really really good
pitcher on their team
as a sophomore he was already getting
looks from big d1 colleges
people were thinking that he'd probably
get drafted right out of high school
very very talented pitcher
and the school wasn't particularly a
baseball powerhouse
uh so the number two pitcher on the team
not a very good pitcher so this guy um
he he very much he thought very strongly
uh and keep in mind we're not dealing
with great decision making here he was
like 16 17 years old
he thought very strongly that his coach
should pitch him every game and high
school baseball
you know you're generally playing about
three games a week give or take two or
three
um but the the coach was pitching him
once a week
uh see seemed to be making pretty good
decisions about a young arm
um because you know pitchers have been
getting tommy john surgery younger and
younger and younger
it's not terribly uncommon for that to
happen in high school these days
uh but his coach seemed to be pretty
smart like hey
i'm gonna pitch my ace once a week we're
gonna lose a lot of games
we'll win those games and that's fine
this is high school baseball it's not
life or death uh but this kid didn't
have much perspective
had a just a full-on screaming match
with his coach before a game because his
coach wouldn't pitch him came to a fever
pitch
uh and so his his coach suspended him
from the team for a month like
hey kid like you're a child i'm trying
to
keep you safe um you you
clearly have no perspective on this so
just like step away for a little bit
uh and try to get your head right and so
he used that uh that time away from the
sport
to try to prove to his coach that his
coach was wrong for not pitching him
every game um so he decided
he was going to throw 500 pitches a day
oh my god every day over that month that
he was suspended
anyway i think he made it longer than is
reasonable
i think he made it through about a week
and a half uh and then he tore his owner
collateral ligament
um his shoulder was really jacked up by
that point as well
he thought he'd just be able to push
through it anyway
got tommy john's surgery again as like a
16 17 year old child
uh never fully recovered and uh
yeah you've you've never heard of this
kid for good reason i don't think he
ever pitched at a high level again
man and just to give um some context
when when people start managing a kid's
pitch count at that age usually if
you're getting into the hundreds it's
like you got to get them off the mound
yeah and give them a week to recover and
then he'll pitch next week
and maybe throw 100. so the idea of 500
a day for people who are not
uh into baseball absolutely insane it's
absolutely insane
i did uh so when i was in high school
around that age
uh a little bit younger actually um but
i was
in high school and i played for a team
and we would travel to the tournaments
and stuff
and play several games in a weekend and
because of those pitch count limitations
if you had a pitcher or two who was
unavailable that weekend
you were in a tight spot because you
can't just throw your your
the same guy for like 200 pitches right
uh
and so every now and then people like me
would have to pitch at these tournaments
who i was not a pitcher i was like
second base shortstop
but i had pitched you know in my younger
years so i could get on the hill
uh and you know throw the ball around a
little bit so they put me in for this
game
and they're like all right eric let's
you know just try not to do anything too
badly you know try to be generally okay
and uh so i didn't throw very hard
but i had very good control of the ball
i could put it where i wanted it to go
and so i ended up you know i threw an
inning leave me in there things are
going well through another inning leave
me in
and because i didn't throw too hard i i
don't think i could even generate enough
force to damage
my elbow or shoulder so i i threw like a
145
pitch complete game uh we won it and
then
here's the the kicker three weeks later
we played that same team
we threw our ace and they pummeled him
and we lost by
like eight uh so from that point forward
even though i sucked at pitching i
i considered myself the best pitcher on
the team you were like a young greg
maddox
yes that'd be a terrible way to
charitable way to put it but
one thing i did want to mention though
you mentioned uh tommy john's surgery
in in teenagers becoming more and more
common
um if you want to take a look into the
dystopian world
of uh baseball recruiting
there was a time period there i don't
know if it still exists
today but for a while there it was
actually
um when people were recruiting you know
pitchers
looking for arm talent the fact that
someone had tommy john's surgery was
actually seen as a plus
they already got it out of their system
yeah so so
the tommy john surgery that ucl
reconstruction
had come along far enough that people
were recovering pretty well
in general people typically did and the
re you know the the reconstructions of
that uh
ligament were durable and so a lot of
the recruits from major league baseball
programs would say
awesome somebody else paid for it not on
us
and uh we can trust that that elbow is
gonna be good to go from here on out
so that alone is bad but
the part that is really dystopian and
messed up
is that parents they're not dummies they
were getting word of
that and people were like hey um
you should go in and preemptively have
a surgeon sever your child's ucl
and then rebuild it better like people
were going
out of their way to try to get uh
access to preemptive ucl
reconstructions so that they could bring
their kid around to all these
uh you know baseball scouts and say
check it out we put a brand new ucl on
them
it's a great ucl it's going to be there
for 20 years
you're just showing off that elbow scar
like your [ __ ] harry potter
exactly yeah they're like check it out
we we did some like we did some updates
here's the boy who was promised exactly
that's so bad and like i'm not a
baseball insider
that's the buzz i heard in the sports
medicine circles uh
not people who are you know tremendously
informed but
i i have heard rumblings of that if it's
total bs that was just a rumor i
apologize in advance but
i i it seems quite plausible to me
i've heard similar speculation about uh
paralympic powerlifting bench pressers
there are a few countries that
absolutely dominate that and if you look
up some of the records
they're [ __ ] crazy the paralympic
benchers are
so strong it's ridiculous so a rumor
i've heard
which i haven't been able to corroborate
which i haven't
tried particularly hard to corroborate
uh
is that for some of those very dominant
paralympic
bench press countries they'll find
people with talent
uh in a similar type thing they'll
just detach and reattach the pec tendon
a little bit further down the humerus so
the internal moment arm is longer and
you can create
more shoulder horizontal flexion torque
per unit of
pec contractile strength um
which i mean the physics checkout
yeah if that's happening very bad
don't approve of it hope it's not yeah
there are also
you could do a whole show on this but
back in the day uh
with olympic athletes there have been a
lot of tremendously unethical things
that have been done
uh to to try to give athletes
a better chance of of training
effectively or performing better
uh you know really invasive medical
procedures that are just
completely despicable and not not okay
um but anyway we need to we need like a
second
good good news segment or something here
uh
let's what's the next question yeah so
uh jboykin14
asks can you hit yourself into marathon
shape
can you get into marathon shape just by
doing high intensity
interval training nice easy one over the
plate there i like that
not sure why you asked me uh but
uh i'm going to say no
but i'm also going to say yes if you go
with a very
loose definition of hit training
um and i mostly just want to talk about
one of the more impressive athletes ever
that i think more people
outside of the endurance training
community should know about and that is
emile
zatto peck uh who was a and i'm
sure i'm mispronouncing that name uh but
he was a
czechoslovakian distance runner mostly a
middle distance guy
but he holds the distinction of being
the only person who ever won
the 5 000 meter 10 000 meter
and marathon distance at the same
olympics so
in helsinki in 52 5k
all the way up to marathon he he won
them all and
i think the marathon at that olympics
was the first time he'd ever run a
marathon
um so anyway very very
impressive endurance athlete he won
five olympic medals over his career set
18 world records
um so yeah just a dominant runner from
the late 40s early 50s
and one of the interesting things about
him is his
training was very unique at the time so
back then most of the time if you were
gonna run long distances
you would run long distances and he was
pretty famous
for doing not all of his training but a
very very hefty proportion of it
just as 400 meter repeats um
and so like a workout for him you know
might start with like
some light jogging to warm up and then
somewhere between 20 and 40
400 meter repeats um the the first ones
were more of a warm up so he'd run them
uh at like a minute 15 give or take and
the last ones were more of a cool down
he'd run those around a minute 15
and then the middle ones were his real
working sets
where he'd run them in just a shade over
a minute which
if you've ever run a 400 meter sprint
anywhere close to all
out it [ __ ] sucks and then just run
40 of them um so if you go with a really
really loose definition of what hit is
uh
zadopeck was doing something like that
uh and
was a very good runner yeah i mean
i i think if if you want to train for a
marathon you're going to want to put in
some mileage you know you're going to
want to
get acclimated to that style of running
uh and get some of those miles under
your belt
but but i do think um oh that's the
other thing about him by the way
what so not only did he train with
mostly just doing 400 meter repeats he
was putting in
insane mileage just doing 400 meter
repeats
so uh in i believe 1942
no no so that this was from uh article
in athletics weekly published in 1954.
um he he was talking about just what his
monthly mileage
looked like throughout a year or i guess
kilometerage
um in march of that year he put in a
total of
kilometers worth of 400 meter repeats
which you can do the math but that's
like that's like close to 150 miles a
week right
i have no idea it's uh the kilometer to
mile thing is never going to work
for me anyway that's an enormous amount
of distance
which if you're just if you're a high
level runner and you're putting in over
100 miles a week
mostly doing zone one training that's
still
a lot of miles to be running pretty fast
400 meter repeats
and that [ __ ] many of them that's
insane
um so yeah a combination of training at
faster average speeds than most people
and greater mileage than most people
it's honestly a wonder that he survived
uh
but he did and he was very good yeah
um but yeah just to
that is a very interesting story i had
never
uh heard of that that that's good stuff
uh but
to give a practical answer to the
listener
um that certainly would not be the
default style of training
uh for most people who are trying to get
into marathon shape
we're really not the people to ask i
feel like
zordos has run marathons in the past he
would be the person to
to ask about this but generally speaking
you want to get acclimated to
you know pretty high mileage running at
an intensity that's going to be
relatively close to what you're doing on
competition
you know some people make a big mistake
of doing too much mileage run into
some overuse injuries in their training
program some people also run into the
issue of neglecting some of the higher
intensity work which which does come in
handy as kind of a
a supplementary effort to uh facilitate
you know
people think marathon they think low
intensity running but there are going to
be bouts where where you're really
digging deep and stressing
the glycolytic energy system so i think
the ideal
approach would be plenty of mileage
making sure that it's
structured sensibly so that you are able
to really acclimate
up to the high mileage required but
supplemented with some of the higher
intensity work so i think
interval training certainly can have a
place there but uh
unless you're going to be the type of
runner that they tell stories about
in 50 years it's probably not the
default style that you want to take
correct i i think there's some uh some
athletes are unique
in terms of how they how they do things
and what they can get away with while
still being remarkably successful
um that does remind me though the idea
of doing all those repeats
um i might have told the story before i
can't remember but
we're getting to that point with a
podcast where it's like
you know your your grandfather who's
just telling you the story they've told
you 13 times but you just got to let him
go
you got to let him do it yeah um so
back in my day exactly so
uh when i was in high school uh the
football coach was like hey this spring
you should practice with the track team
you know
uh work on your high end speed that'll
be good for for a defensive back i said
sure that'll be great
um so i go out to my first practice with
the track team and you know this is you
know these
people are fast as a hobby and the
workout was a bunch of repeated 200
meter sprints
and uh and so i get up to the starting
line and
i'm like you know what i can do anything
that these trumps can do
and i kind of want to prove myself you
know i'm this visitor who's kind of
jumping in on the practices so i
you know i want to make a good
impression i don't want to be the slow
guy from the football team
uh so you know we get up to the starting
line ready set
go and as i expected
i i leave those people in the dust i
i really embarrassed them it was pretty
impressive
and for the next like minute as we were
kind of catching our breath getting
ready for the next one i'm thinking
i don't know maybe maybe i will be on
the track team you know maybe i'll be
the captain i don't know that'd be fine
i've got plenty of time this spring uh i
do the second one
beat the hell out of everybody and it
was going pretty well
about halfway through i realized they
were pacing themselves
i didn't know that was an option uh from
my experience of sprinting was that you
give a hundred percent effort
and then your effort just deteriorates
over time that was how
they shouldn't have caught them 200
meter sprints well
if you're pacing yourself whatever the
hell they were doing was not what i was
doing
but by the end of it i found out i was
not in fact the fact
the fastest person on the track team i
was just the only one stupid enough to
give a full effort on the first couple
and by the end of it i was like about to
throw i've never thrown up from exercise
but that was the closest i've ever been
and uh everybody else was just doing
fine and
it was almost the fact that nobody told
me i think
might qualify as hazing because like
they knew what was going down and i
think they really enjoyed watching me
uh physically fall apart in front of
them ah that's
that's rough yeah they should have given
me a heads up but
but for i mean for those like two or
three minutes it was pretty incredible
like i really believed
that i was like probably the fastest
person that i knew
i was like this is great uh
okay is that it for the q a's uh that's
it for reddit i'm gonna
pull two from the facebook group as well
all right
all right so uh katie ford
asks uh what's the best tendon
strengthening protocol
um also not entirely sure why this is
directed
at us but my understanding so i'm
getting this
from uh a talk uh i saw derek miles give
three or four years ago i trust derek
good guy
um and so what he was talking
in this this was a clinical athlete
event
uh that they held in asheville several
years back by the way
if you're interested in like
science-based
physical therapy rehab stuff check out
clinical athlete
very good organization they definitely
know what they're talking about
um and if you're interested in finding
a a physical therapist
that understands the demands of lifters
they have
uh on their website like a physical
therapist locator tool
where you can find someone who is kind
of within the clinical athlete
network uh so that that's a good if you
live in the u.s i don't know if they've
gone international yet
but if you live in the u.s that's that's
a good resource to be aware of
um and if you like beer or mountains be
sure to check out asheville as well
which is where the event was that you
mentioned or crystals
that's a throwback oh yeah uh but yeah
anyway so
uh what derek was talking about was that
basically it seems
that just load and resistance is the
important thing
um so the folks used to say that
say isometrics were the bee's knees and
then they were talking about heavy
eccentrics as being very important
to tendon rehab and tendon strengthening
uh and now now it just seems like
anything that
um is heavy enough that you have to move
it pretty slowly
probably gets the job done um and so
when it comes to
strengthening your tendons you just want
to be putting
[Music]
a pretty high load through them that
they can still tolerate pretty well
and beyond that it's just a matter of
load management so if you're
you know if if the total dosage of
exercise or the frequency of exercise
is such that the tendons can't fully
recover and remodel after it
that can cause degenerative changes and
if the
dose of exercise is enough to adequately
stress the tendon but you let it recover
adequately before exposing it to further
load
then that helps strengthen the tendons
so you know
and and that dose is going to vary
person to person depending whether
they're healthy or not
if they're not kind of where they are in
the rehab process but
it seems to basically just be a matter
of the total resistance you're putting
through it
and then just basic principles of load
management beyond that
um let's see what's the next
most highly upvoted question oh here's a
good one uh so
m ache asks uh if you could redesign the
presidential
fitness awards to be science-based what
exercises
would you torture kids with in gym class
in order to determine if they were
physically fit
uh yeah that's that's the other one
we're doing
do you want to take a swing at that um i
mean
because it's not an area that is of keen
interest to me um i don't
yeah i don't have like a list of
exercises off the top of my head but
like
you know if i'm thinking of you know
general physical fitness
let's say uh maybe
body weight bench for reps body weight
squat for reps
uh maybe give me like uh
give me like a 200 meter sprint uh
and maybe a broad jump you know let's
get let's get upper body strength
endurance lower body strength endurance
uh the broad jump for for explosive
power and uh
and yeah yeah something to test the
anaerobic system
um i i just i want to say uh
that is like if i was just if someone
came to me as like a
you know a person interested in fitness
and wanted to say hey
you know give me a fitness score i i
don't
think that there's too much value in the
concept of the presidential fitness test
so i don't want it to seem like i'm
saying hey we should make all the kids
do that and then
shame the kids who do poorly in it i
think
it's something that ought to be opted
into uh for people who are fitness
enthusiasts and uh and that would be uh
kind of my baseline assessment i guess
but yeah i the i listened to a podcast
about the presidential fitness test that
it was like is this something that we
need and
i don't think the answer is necessarily
yes what was the podcast
uh i think it was you're wrong about it
was the one that you told me about was
it maintenance phase
no i think it's you're wrong about oh i
thought uh i didn't know they
they did one on the presidential fitness
test i think so
uh interesting yeah i thought they did
that on michael's other podcast
maintenance phase
uh regardless i don't think it exists
anymore
uh so i i did some very brief reading on
this
um because i was like oh you know that's
that's a good question i wanted to re
reacquaint myself with what is currently
in the presidential
physical fitness test uh and at least
according to wikipedia
it it's not a thing anymore they
discontinued it
in uh the 2012-2013 school year
um and honestly i think that's a
positive
uh because you know ultimately i think
the question
is uh the the question
underpinning any sort of testing is like
why are we testing this
why does it matter um and i don't know
necessarily what we get out of knowing
what sort of shape
every kid in the nation is in um for
for a lot less money and a lot less time
uh you could just do
like just every year or so just
just fund several labs to bring in say
100 kids at random from
from their community test them and if
you get an idea of where
say like 200 randomly or like 2 000
randomly sampled kids are at you can
have a pretty good idea of
of what the nation looks like like
that's that's enough to establish
normative values
and it's probably not shifting all that
quickly so like just [ __ ] do it once
a decade
that'll be fine um so yeah like
ultimately i don't
i don't know that you really get uh that
much
valuable information from having every
kid in the country do it every single
year so i
if it had not been gotten rid of by now
i probably would have just gotten rid of
it
um and also like one of the things that
one of the things that didn't
necessarily occur to me
when i was a child in doing the
presidential physical fitness test which
uh i became aware of because of i think
we listened to the same podcast i
i it may have been you're wrong about i
really thought it was maintenance phase
but maybe it was you're wrong about
um regardless uh listening to it
one of the things they talked about is
how
children with obesity and children with
low levels of physical
fitness found it like pretty
embarrassing and like slightly traumatic
and i feel like that's probably not a
great thing
so uh at a young age like ultimately
you're trying to hopefully
help people establish a positive
relationship with exercise
and you know if it's the type so
for people outside the u.s uh what
we did growing up and what i guess every
kid did from like the 1950s until 2013
uh was once a year in gym class you
would be put through
uh a battery of tests that the
presidential council
on physical fitness said like hey we
want to know
uh how good a shape all of these
children are in
put them through these battery of tests
and i think people who finished in the
top 15 percent got an award
um and yeah like
so one of them for example was
uh like a uh
they have standing bra jump on here i
don't remember doing bra jump i remember
a shuttle run
uh regardless there were like a battery
of tests and some of them the class
would all do together so like
they did sit-ups and like half the class
would do sit-ups the other
half would like hold the kid's feet um
but then other ones
like flexibility tests or like shuttle
run tests or pull-up tests
like one person would be doing it and
the rest of the class would just be
watching them as they waited for their
turn on the implement
uh and apparently people with with low
physical fitness just really
really didn't like that and it could
create a negative
association with
exercise moving forward from there so
yeah i mean i
i don't think that that's ideal
especially for people with low fitness
you want them to like fitness more not
less
um so yeah i'd probably just scrap the
whole concept
yeah yeah and uh the other thing was
like they would do the the presidential
fitness test and they'd be like good
news greg you suck at everything you
have
like very low fitness level and you
should feel bad about that
and and then greg as a kid says oh cool
what are we going to do about that
what's our program to fix it
like oh nothing but we'll see you again
in a year
yeah yeah like there's just no there's
nothing positive coming from it there
there was they weren't like prescribing
an intervention based on your results
you know
yeah like people who are already doing
well it's like oh cool you're
uh in good shape but you and all of your
peers already knew that and people in
bad shape it's like oh you're in bad
shape
you clearly knew that already your peers
already knew that but
uh let's just make that as patently
obvious as possible
yeah so like i said i just don't think
we have a need for it um
i think like fitness testing should be
something that's opted into
uh for people who want that information
uh but
one thing i would add to my battery of
tests that i i gave out there just for
for having some type of answer add the
two mile run to that
why because i didn't have an endurance
metric
and the two mile run was always my
favorite distance to run see i'm looking
through this and i feel like when we did
the presidential physical fitness test
when i was in elementary school
we didn't do the actual presidential
physical fitness test because i'm
looking through this and there's
maybe your gym teacher was like screw it
we're doing our own thing i mean maybe
so what what i'm seeing the tests are is
the yard dash
600 yard run standing bra jump
i didn't do any of this stuff pull-ups
for boys flexed arm hang for girls
sit-ups and shuttle run oh i just missed
shuttle run it was on here
um but yeah so i remember doing
uh the pull-ups the sit-ups
and the shuttle run but then we did we
did push-ups
yeah we did push-ups we did a mile run
maybe it changed over time
i don't know who's to say well it was it
was never based on
anything substantial so it's easy to
change things that have no
uh solid basis for their development
uh i wouldn't be shocked if they just
tweaked it whenever they felt like it
so i think it was based on something
either way this is not the the time to
do
if you want to more in uh info on the
history of it uh
we we can link to that that episode yeah
and there's also
uh a good article on vox title is a
brief history of the bizarre and
sadistic presidential fitness test um
apparently it started because like these
people who were high level climbers came
up with a fitness
test they administered it to a bunch of
american kids and a bunch of
uh swiss kids like back in the 50s
and um and also austrian kids
and something like 58 of the us children
failed the test and
only eight percent of the europeans did
uh and they took that to
dwight eisenhower and he said [ __ ] we
gotta do something about this
also that's another thing that's kind of
wild uh
if you if you talk to anyone these days
uh about like what type of shape kids
are in they're like ah back in my day
everyone was in such good shape and kids
these days
ah they're in bad shape but like that's
been the narrative
apparently since the 50s um
so who's to say man i remember looking
into this research
a while back and basically like the
scores on the presidential fitness test
hadn't changed even as like uh
activity levels in childhood were going
down or at least on most of the tests
suggesting that like maybe testing is
pointless in the first place because
you know kids are going to go along kind
of a natural course of development
some will be in good shape some will be
in bad shape and
who know who knows why that happens and
you know
trainability is more robust after uh
after puberty
regardless weird stuff uh i don't have
good vibes about the presidential
physical fitness test
no we are completely out of time
so uh no time for the to play us out
segment you're gonna have to play
yourselves out today
what no time for it we gotta go uh we
will be back in a couple weeks with
another one though
and uh i'm sure it'll be great
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs
for all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do
so we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or
registered dietitians so before you make
any changes to your exercise or
nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified health
care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
you